the well-deserved fame guadalajara's
main plaza or so cool rests in the great
merit of her architectural monuments
which clearly interpret the achieving
spirit that has made her the proud
second city the republic boasting a
population of two hundred thousand souls
outlined against the background of the
plaza we see the stately towers of the
cathedral a magnificent structure which
has contributed greatly to the
reputation of this city founded by Don
Juan de oñate a trusted lieutenant of
the incredible anon Cortez in 15-30
Guadalajara knees were worshiping and
enjoying its beauty in hometown comfort
nearly a hundred years before the
arrival of the Puritans at Plymouth
fronting one side of the square stands
the governor's palace behind a
magnificent force earn through its lofty
portals past untold numbers of judges
and other vice regal officials during
centuries of Spanish splendor
outstanding among the city's wealth of
beautiful old edifices is the church and
convent of Santa Monica in its
exceptionally fine stone carving we
cannot fail to sense the refinement of
an age that achieved immortality through
its attention to artistic detail such as
spirit bequeaths indescribable beauty to
posterity
the museum of ancient history has been
established in this lovely old building
which was itself formerly a convent
in closing a spacious courtyard is a
particularly noble arcade its lines
speak eloquently of the aesthetic
development of its constructors
within our to be seen many and valuable
relics religious ornaments and jewels as
well as glorious canvases from the
fifteenth sixteenth and seventeenth
centuries works of the Masters Maria
Cabrera and Juarez hang here
the requirements of the everyday visitor
are not neglected either in this city of
fine values a very latest in hotel
facilitation and comfort is courteously
provided for the enjoyment alike of the
foreign tourists and mexican compadres
on holiday some 25 kilometers outside
Guadalajara are the Falls of wonnacott
land which today provide the city in
many adjacent communities with an
abundance of light and power
the ancient legend that in order to
ensure good luck in later life newlyweds
must visit this fall his remindful of
our own Niagara honeymoon tradition
the bright foam melts mystically in the
soft breezes of Alice co-creating a
moment of rainbow Beauty to mark the
transition